Nickel is element number 28,
between cobalt 27 and copper 29.
Nickel has been known for a long time as an element or the mixture with other
metals,
but it was only isolated as an element in 1751 by
Axel Friedrich,
crunched it in Sweden to begin with it didn't have really much
use.
And the big breakthrough for nickel came in the 19th century.
When it was discovered that if you added an eco to steel,
you could make very strong armor,
particularly armor plates for ships so that your ship was
stronger than the enemies and their cells couldn't penetrate about the
same time, a large deposit of nickel or nickel,
or was discovered in Sudbury, in Ontario and Canada.
So that in some ways nickel has become a Canadian
element. There are also no large deposits in Russia,
but the Canadians have become so proud of nickel, Axel, Friedrich,
crunched it,
his portraits is on the premiere metal of the Canadian Institute of
chemistry.
It is thought that the nickel deposits in Canada probably came with a meteorite
from outer space because meteorites quite often
have a very high nickel content.
And presumably in the very distant past a massive meter rate
struck what is now Canada and buried itself in the Sudbury
region, you don't need a very large diameter to meet, to write,
to contain an awful lot of metal.
The big breakthrough in the refining of nickel came in
1890. When the British chemist Ludvik Mons,
who was a major industrialists,
had a problem in his chemical works that some of the
nickel valves on his chemical plants were found to corrode
dissolve, and he discovered,
or his assistant clinker discovered that this was caused by reaction
between carbon monoxide and nickel in 1890,
they published the key paper about the compound.
The compound is called nickel Tetra combination.
It consists of essential NIC LATAM surrounded by four carbon
monoxide groups arranged in the tetrahedron.
What made this compound really unusual is that when you think about
transition metals, iron copper, nickel,
you think of colored salts, which are solid all the time.
Nickel Campanile was a liquid.
It was colorless and it boiled at 43 degrees centigrade.
So it was almost a gas at room temperature.
The important thing about nickel Campanile is that you can distill it
easily. And if you heat it up,
it decomposes back into nickel and carbon monoxide.
So it turned out to be really good way of purifying nickel
or Amman set up a company specifically to get
nickel from the oars in Sudbury.
So he was reacting your with carbon monoxide,
which extracted out the nickel. And in fact, some of the iron,
both as these so-called carbonated compounds,
you can then separate them by distillation,
heat them up to decompose them and you get absolutely pure nickel and
some iron as well.
It was then discovered that nickel was a very good catalyst
for reacting organic compounds with hydrogen.
And particularly it was discovered that you put hydrogenate
vegetable oils, sort of cooking oils that you use.
And these oils have carbon carbon, double bonds.
If you react these with hydrogen,
the melting point of the oils increases.
So the material becomes more like butter,
and this is how you make March serene by reacting vegetable oil
with hydrogen. The nickel is the catalyst.
The hydrogen is absorbed onto the surface of nickel.
The organic compounds also absorbed on the surface
and when the molecules are held there,
the hydrogen can transfer from the nickel onto the carbon of
the double bond.
I was very keen to do a big experiments
demonstration in this video.
And I wanted to do it with a material called rainy.
Nicole Marie Rainey was an American chemist working on the
hydrogenation of fats, trying to make a better catalyst.
And the problem with the catalyst is because it is solid and the
molecules are absorbing on the surface, the bigger,
the surface area within reason, the better the catalyst.
So he needed some way of dividing up the nickel.
So it was in very small particles.
So it had a very large surface area and he hit on the idea of
mixing molten,
aluminum and molten nickel,
these melted metals,
and they mix when they are liquid, but when they solidify,
they separate.
So you end up with a lump of aluminum,
with tiny bits of nickel embedded in the
solid, rather like currents or cherries in the cake.
You can then put these mixed nickel,
aluminum pellets into sodium hydroxide.
[Inaudible].
The sodium hydroxide dissolves the Ellie minium,
rather like we've done before with Coke cans and they
leave the nickel quite untouched,
but they come out like removing the cherries from the cake
and they have a very low surface area.
[Inaudible].
So now my experiments,
I had read that Raney nickel is para
Foric. It reacts with oxygen, the air and burst into flames.
So I went to talk to my colleagues in organic chemistry who use Raymond
nickel and you buy it as a slurry.
So it's wet to avoid it bursting into flames.
So I got a bottle which looked a bit old,
but I was assured was probably okay.
And I persuaded Neil to pour it onto a filter paper.
And so what I expected was that it would dry out and then you
would be left with these dry, tiny particles of nickel,
which would absorb oxygen,
start burning heat up more and more and burst into spectacular flames.
Unfortunately, it didn't. In fact,
when Neil eventually set fire to the filter paper and the
nickel didn't seem to burn,
clearly we had the data batch.
I think that the air had got in and slowly dissolved in the water and
reacted over a period of months and oxidized the nickel.
So probably what we had was some form of nickel oxide,
but they're all fairly black and colors.
So you can't really tell what you've got.
So I rushed off and found another professor who had much fresher sample
and he came down with his sample and he told us we had to dry it on a hot
plate. And he got quite worried thought,
we'd use rather a lot of nickel. We heated it up. We had all the cameras,
the GoPro,
the thermal camera braids is standing there so excited
and eventually it loads likely.
And what this demonstrates is that sometimes
what chemists tell you about reactions are not
always what's happens in the lab. However,
you've got to imagine that if you're making margarine on a huge
scale, tens of thousands of tons,
and they've got a huge amount of rainy nickel,
then probably you can get quite a serious fire,
but we don't have that much rain in nickel. And we don't want the series foam.
So well, first of all, let's look at some nickel.
Neil has produced some Nick pellets.
So these are just labeled as general purpose nickel.
They're lumps of nickel,
quite a few chemists like to use nickels bachelor's
because they are more resistant to strong acids
than stainless steel ones. You can have over here.
This is quite nice.
This is doors that is made of very fine
nickel whales. I think this one is designed for electric chemistry.
So you can get a very high surface area.
Nicholas has also been used quite often for electroplating
in the days when cars had shiny bumpers.
I can't remember what to American school bumpers fenders and
these consisted of steel, which were plated with nickel.
And on top of the nickel was chromium. So the chromium gave a nice,
shiny look, but the Nicole bonded them together.
Nickel.
Has very colorful salts and our
undergraduates in their first year do a very nice experiment where they
take nickel chloride that is green,
and they react this with ammonia so that
each Nicole LATAM is surrounded by six ammonia.
Atoms. The nickel ammonia complex is a nice purple color.
They then have to do a separate experiment to measure how much nickel
is in the sample to see if they made it properly.
They do this by dissolving up their nice to put a compound,
adding an organic compound called Damien,
which binds to the nickel and forms an insoluble red
precipitate,
which they filter off and way so they can see how much nickel there is in their
compounds. So in a single experiment,
they have gone from green to purple to red.
We're not showing you the experiment because then those students might cheat.
So you'll have to come as a student to do it yourself.
[Inaudible].
Then Neil thought about it.
He realized that as the water was evaporating and the individual
particles of nickel got dry, each of them oxidized.
So you've never had a whole mass going off at once.
So what he decided was to put the wet rainy nickel
in a vacuum desiccated.
This is a vessel which you can pump out all the air and as you're pumping on it,
of course the water also evaporates,
but the nickel is dried in a vacuum. So there's no oxygen for it to react with.
So when you open the tap, the air containing the oxygen rushed in
and all the nickel reacted at the same time and produced quite a satisfying
Bush.
Video is about every element on the periodic table.
If you'd like to watch them in order,
I'll put a link on the screen and in the video description as a playlist of the
mole, one to 118 might take you a little while.
We're constantly updating these videos with new ones,
like the nickel video you just watched. And in fact,
we've filmed so much about nickel. There's some leftovers.
If you'd like to watch them, I'm also linking to the extra footage.
You can go and check out even more details that professor had to share.